you know just like me on stage now when
the night is just right you don't say
dude you look [ __ ] fantastic for 70
times you tell you I thought you were
seven nails like holy [ __ ] you look
really good and he's amazing thank you
it really does Thanks and I walk around
like this and wonder why everybody's
[ __ ] taking pictures and busting my
chops walking through the airport I
actually have a t-shirt that says go
[ __ ] yourself e cuz you're walking with
the dogs you're walking with the girl
you were and they come over and want to
stop take a selfie something thank you
thank you so it is well I don't know
30 years of it on drugs and drunk
so maybe the crystal helped you I think
so I say something yeah how long you be
carrying nothing around
I don't it lives in my house I got is
not here today
Oh what is that you British switchblade
Joe Perry and I got a thing Oh nobody
switchblade we just collect knives man
we're just well you know I'm such a
country boy and when I did Idol every
night when I walked out on stage and
went biddy biddy biddy biddy biddy
and I'm walking next to JLo and Randy my
knife was right in my pocket in case
just one thing no open my fan mail oh
okay
yeah switchblade to open fit it's it's
fun it's a cool thing is fun I don't
often carry it but I I thought because I
think you're so [ __ ] cool then I
would bring a couple of cool things from
my house you know I'm just like that
oh thank you I'm one of those guys who
want to leave the house I go say goodbye
house remember I got a son and three
daughters right so and I know after
watching what was the what was your last
triggered that you got a bunch of kids
too and it starts wearing off on you I
say it's a beautiful thing I think it's
a beautiful thing to hear three girls
wife and two girls I have three girls
three Thor's oh wait it will happen to
you I do too oh yeah
you're a legit eccentric like there's
some people that pretend to be eccentric
mm-hmm you're like a legit one I am and
I love it in fact I love me it's good to
love more than that I love us I love us
too I love us I say there I'm super
happy about this
I'm so [ __ ] excited okay seriously I
gotta ask you what the [ __ ] do you eat
for breakfast
how did you get so [ __ ] smart oh I
just remember things okay cuz there's a
difference there's a difference between
being smart and just remembering a lot
okay you everything yeah I'm not that
smart
well remembering things is huge it helps
certainly helps yeah but what is smart
right smart is like can you solve
equations can you figure things out that
other people can't figure out do you
know things other people don't know no I
just remember [ __ ] that smart people
have already figured out but you
accumulate situations Jimi Hendrix say
experience yeah experiential so if you
remember those things over and over
you're gonna become a wizard your wisdom
is so good thank you